[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome to certified country I'm Sylvia
Lacey and today's show is extra special
because we are taking you inside Tyler
and Haley Hubbard's home to meet the
newest member of the Florida Georgia
line family five month old baby Olivia
the timing couldn't have been better for
a little crash course in parenting as
I'm expecting my first also a girl in
August
[Music]
I want to tell you guys a story in my
first trimester pretty early on I'm not
a crier
at all I'm really not but I was sitting
in my car and God your mama and me came
on the radio and I started bawling out
of nowhere oh I'm pregnant
okay like I'm literally tearing out
because I'm so emotional
[Laughter]
Tyler admits he's gone a little soft
since welcoming his daughter last
December trading rockstar life for dad's
life we turn to know people would get a
bed really early we got a business and
pretty much as soon as she's out we're
sleep as well and then we're up at 7:00
every single morning she's so happy in
the mornings so that's like some of our
favorite times I think she might be a
little hand what are you guys hey she's
definitely she's gonna top a lot yeah
he's got some pipes I think she might be
a singer mm-hmm yes you definitely find
in her voice let's just say that
sometimes got a little talk gets a
little louder okay as a musician is that
something that you encourage with her
like are you I think it'll be I think so
I think it'll be fun to play music
around her a lot and play piano and I
hope that she wants to do the same and
hopefully she can pick up on it did you
play her after G L music when she was in
the belly oh yeah we meant to be she
would always start singing
[Music]
how is the next album coming along and
is live inspiring any of that music oh
absolutely
the fourth album is coming along great
and I would definitely say that live has
had a huge influence on on the writing
and the content of the song as you know
there's a song called women on there's
which is definitely her and Haley both
inspired you know all the songs honestly
I've heard inspired from our life where
we're at right now and I think there's a
lot of special songs on there I can't
wait for you to hear but we still got
the party jams not all sensitive fans
can expect a new single from FGL this
summer as for expanding the family Tyler
isn't so sure except the intimate Brian
Kelly is in any hurry for kids of his
own
every time I ask BK about it he just
says he's gonna stick to his dogs for a
while mess is good too and he's got his
fur babies and I will say that they're
great parents day and that's a lot of
responsibility as well I mean they got
four dogs and they got a lot going on in
really I think it's all about timing and
they and you know for them they both say
they want to have kids so they'll
probably will but I think it'll just be
a little while I've told him no pressure
no pressure no pressure we're just gonna
we're just gonna but you better hurry
but no pressure so are you guys thinking
about more kids I think we're gonna end
up if it's God's plan hopefully with
three kids we've talked about possibly
adopting one day as well so I don't know
if that'll be the second or third kid
but we're just gonna let a year to go by
enjoy enjoyed figuring out how to be
parents and then see where it goes it's
adoption something you've talked to
Thomas right about yeah we were kind of
there in the middle of their situation
as well when they were adopting uh
Willie gray and definitely an inspiring
situation the love that they have for
that little girl and that she has for
them it's just so cool and to see see
the difference you can make in
somebody's life like they fought against
all odds I mean truly sure before saying
goodbye I had to get in just one more
question with the whole family to get
Tyler what has been the biggest change
you've seen in Hailey since she became a
mother um you know what I think it's
just cool to see the love of a mother
and how a child comes first now and I
think it's at first it was an adjustment
for me you know and I mean it's like
wait you're fixing bottle you're not
making me breakfast what's going on over
there but it kind of draws me even
closer to hailey just watching her being
mom and there's just a cool new layer of
intimacy all all the way around the
board Haley what's the biggest change
you've seen in Tyler I can see you have
a lot more patience now it's just like
kind of was like an overnight thing
right you just realized things are gonna
take longer than when they normally take
it and that's fun but also just to watch
you the way you look at her and just
care for her is special and something's
so attractive about that you've also
been really I think diligent about like
making time for us which is nice you can
kind of give a hundred percent to the
baby when you're both kind of reach
hours and you've had a night together
you know is that once a week or so
definitely try to adjust it even if it's
at the house here and have dinner alone
and have some last night we had a
babysitter come over we didn't even
leave the house just making sure that
once a week or so would just have a
couple hours to kind of spend to get
here recharge so that we can be the best
we can be you know you aren't lucky
little lady look at my arms muscles all
right control thank you so much guys
thank you for inviting us into your home
and sharing your beautiful baby thank
you next time you don't have to bring
yours we could have a little baby all
right would love that
how sweet is that family I really hope
you enjoyed this week's episode but
there is even more to come next week
I'll bring you my exclusive interview
with brian kelly and his wife Brittany
all about their growing fashion empire
tribe Callie you're not gonna want to
miss it so be sure to subscribe to
Entertainment Tonight on
YouTube we are gonna have a brand new
episode of certified country for you
next Friday see it